the end of christmas and the end of the
school holidays for 17 year old amelia
the start of the new term means the
return of masks in class with exams
coming up she doesn't mind if it keeps
her sixth form open i've got exam mocks
coming up um wednesday so
um by going into school and doing them
in there if everyone else is there then
i feel like it's fairer um on pretty
much everyone in my year group um it's
better just to be all in doing the same
thing all at the same time you go
darling
thanks mom
and for her mum claire anything is
better than teenagers homeschooling it's
not ideal nothing's ideal i mean bubbles
aren't ideal um
if they need to budge up
open a few more windows
that's what but yeah let's not produce
let's not keep them at home anymore
we need they need to be there
and
and
and just be children
from this week masks will be mandatory
in secondary schools they'll be regular
testing and classes could merge if
teachers are off sick
schools have of course been here before
but ministers insist this time the
priority is staying open the exams will
go ahead the most important thing for me
is to make sure children are in school
with their teachers in the class
learning and of course we'll go we'll do
everything in our power to make sure
that happens
but there is real worry schools could
struggle to stay open
staffing's the problem before christmas
at least eight percent of teachers were
off and cases could creep up among
children too
that's why unions say the government
should have acted sooner the challenge
is for schools who will do their best to
stay open and to educate peoples face to
face because that's what teachers and
leaders want to do and we know that's
the best for the pupils but if
government ministers are really serious
if nadine tahawi really had done
everything humanly possible then he
would have introduced mask wearing
earlier and he would have got
ventilation units into every classroom
that needs them we have though come a
long way a year ago schools were told to
close remote learning now seems less
likely but for schools the coming weeks
will be a challenging new chapter laura
bundock sky news woking in surrey